Nuclear bombs are the most destructive weapons
humanity has ever devised, but they have an
unexpected upside.
Thanks to their development and testing, they’ve
contributed to some surprising advances in
other scientific fields like neuroscience
and climatology.
You may wonder what neuroscience has to do
with nuclear weapons, and to understand the
connection, you need to know about carbon-14.
Usually carbon has an atomic mass of 12; 6
protons and 6 neutrons.
But on occasion, neutrons energized by cosmic
rays from our sun will collide with nitrogen
atoms in our atmosphere, knocking a proton
off the atom and converting nitrogen into
carbon with two extra neutrons, AKA Carbon-14
Unlike its 6 neutron cousin, carbon-14 is
radioactive, with a half-life of about 5,700
years.
To organisms though it doesn’t make much
difference.
Plants use carbon-14 like any other carbon
atom during photosynthesis, and that carbon-14
works its way through the food chain.
That’s right.
All of us have this radioactive isotope spread
throughout our entire bodies.
Since carbon-14 is constantly decaying and
is replenished by natural cycles, the amount
of it in our atmosphere remains pretty constant.
At least it should, so long as nobody’s,
oh I don’t know, setting off massive explosions
that release a lot of high energy neutrons
into our nitrogen-rich atmosphere.
Remember when we did that?
Atomic bombs create an artificial spike in
atmospheric carbon-14, and we can associate
that spike to an exact moment in time.
Since we know how much carbon-14 WAS in the
air for any given year, and we know how carbon
works its way into our bodies…
We can use these spikes to measure how much
carbon-14 is in a cell’s DNA and determine
what year that cell was formed.
Clever scientists realized this gave them
a rare opportunity to answer a vexing question
about the human brain.
The prevailing wisdom had long been that humans
don’t grow new brain cells after early childhood,
but research on rodents and monkeys showed
that wasn’t the case for them.
These animals would grow new neurons in the
hippocampus and olfactory bulb, the areas
associated with memory and smell.
But the method used to track neuron growth
in monkeys couldn’t be used on humans because
it relied on a banned chemical.
So instead, in a small study, researchers
realized if they looked at samples of brain
tissue and checked how much carbon-14 was
present, they could determine when the neurons
formed during that person’s lifetime.
At first, they couldn’t test the hippocampus
because it contained so few neurons, making
carbon-14 too difficult to detect.
But, their initial tests on the larger olfactory
bulb showed that we humans do NOT generate
new olfactory neurons like our smellier monkey
cousins.
But, soon after, advances in DNA sampling
made it possible to scan the hippocampus of
110 brain slices for carbon-14, and VOILA.
They found the average neuron in that region
of the brain was only 20 to 30 years old,
even when the brain was more than 90.
It would seem we do generate new neurons in
the hippocampus after all, about 700 a day
by the researcher’s estimate.
So case closed, right?
We’re done here?
Hahaha, of course not.
A study published in early March went looking
for those new and forming neurons in 59 brains.
While they were abundant in the brains of
children, nary an immature brain cell was
found in adults, challenging the results of
the experiments that relied on Carbon-14.
Maybe there’s another explanation for the
Carbon-14 levels but if we’re going to find
it we better hurry.
The window to test something like this is
closing.
Open air atomic testing was banned in 1963,
and carbon-14 levels are fast approaching
their old pre-atomic levels.
By 2050 researchers believe this sort of carbon-14
testing probably won’t be possible anymore.
You may remember that carbon-14 has a half
life of almost 5,700 years and wondering why
the levels are dropping so fast.
It turns out much of the excess carbon-14
is being absorbed by oceans and organisms,
which has helped scientists understand how
atmospheric CO2 flows.
So in an unexpected way, nuclear weapons have
helped us learn about our planet and our own
brains.
I guess even mushroom clouds have silver linings.
Before we knew about C14, we could track cell
growth with bromodeoxyuridine, but it was
banned because it can harm the fetus in pregnant
women, causing scientists to question the
results.
Thanks for watching Seeker.